Hallo, ich bin Peter Adamson, willkommen zurück zu den
Denkerinnen und der Antike und dem
Mittelalter.
Heute sprechen wir über eine
große Dichterin, eine Denkerin des frühen 14.
Jahrhunderts, die 1310 hingerichtet wurde,
nachdem sie 1308 verhaftet worden war, und dann
sie  wurde wegen ihrer gewagten
theologischen Lehren hingerichtet, also ist dies die
zweite Frau, die wir behandelt haben, die
tatsächlich beide Male von Christen getötet wurde,
also hatten wir den christlichen Mob, der
Hypatia in der Spätantike tötete, und jetzt haben
wir die christlichen Behörden, die
Marguerite in den Tod bringen  Anfang des 14.
Jahrhunderts
offensichtlich in einem ganz anderen Kontext,
und um Ihnen einen gewissen Veteranenstatus
des Kontexts zu vermitteln, in dem
Margarete hingerichtet wurde, wollte
ich zuerst etwas allgemeineres über
das Muster der Unterdrückung und
Verurteilung theologischer und
philosophischer Ideen in lateinischer Sprache sagen  mittelalterliches
Europa, also ist dies ein Bereich, in dem ich denke,
dass die Leute viele Missverständnisse haben,
insbesondere ich nehme an, dass viele
Leute das tun würden  Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das christliche
mittelalterliche Europa wirklich eine
Umgebung war, in der fast niemand
etwas sagen konnte, dass sie überhaupt außerhalb
der Grenzen der orthodoxen christlichen
Lehren traten, also der von der Kirche festgelegten Dogmen,
und tatsächlich ist es sehr verbreitet
, eine Art Annahme über die mittelalterliche
Philosophie zu haben  und Theologie, die wirklich
nur eine ständige Wiederholung der gleichen
Ideen ist, also in der Philosophie,
die Aristoteles in der Theologie
immer wieder wiederholt, wiederholen sie einfach große
theologische Autoritäten wie sagen wir Agustin
oder Peter Lombard und es macht nie
Fortschritte, es ist alles ziemlich langweilig und
wir wirklich.  Sie sind nur eine Art Zeitmarkierung, in der Sie darauf
warten, dass der Schwanzschnitt auftaucht
und die moderne Philosophie in Gang setzt. Das ist also
eine Art von Annahmen und Vorurteilen
, die die Menschen über das Mittelalter
haben, eine andere Art von Annahmen und
Vorurteilen ist, dass dieses Phänomen
auf die Originalität des Mittelalters zurückgeht
Denken und die weit verbreitete Unterdrückung
und das Verbot bestimmter Ideen im
mittelalterlichen p  Die Epoche würde sich auf andere
mittelalterliche Kulturen und
insbesondere auf die islamische Welt der
gleichen
Zeit erstrecken, also habe ich mich viel mit
der Annahme beschäftigt, dass Denker in der
islamischen Welt, also Juden und Christen, aber
insbesondere Muslime, die unter dem Islam leben
und sagen wir, von der  9. bis
13. Jahrhundert hätten fast keine
Freiheit gehabt, ihre Ideen zu erforschen, und
wären wiederum wirklich an die
Zwänge ihrer Kultur gebunden gewesen
, also möchte ich dazu ein paar Dinge sagen, die
ich zuerst erklären möchte
Diese Situation in der islamischen Welt
war eigentlich ganz anders als diese
Situation in der lateinischen Christenheit, und dann
möchte ich etwas mehr über die
Situation wie die Christenheit sagen, und ich werde
mehr darüber sagen, weil das
als Kontext für Margarete offensichtlich relevanter ist,
aber zuerst nur kurz  Zur islamischen
Situation finden Sie sogar in
veröffentlichten Forschungsergebnissen von Experten der islamischen
Philosophie die Vorstellung, dass die Möglichkeit
o  f Unterdrückung oder sogar Schwierigkeiten zu bekommen,
wie ernsthafte Probleme wie Verhaftung
oder Tod, könnte ein wirklich
wichtiger Faktor bei der Bestimmung der Art und Weise gewesen sein
, wie Philosophen in der islamischen Welt
ihre Werke schrieben, so dass man manchmal
den Verdacht sieht, dass sie vielleicht
ihre wahren Lehren dahinter stecken  eine Art
Schleier der Geheimhaltung, vielleicht haben sie eine
Art Code oder bedeutungsvolles Schweigen in
ihren Werken hinterlassen, um Ihnen zu helfen, zu verstehen, was
sie wirklich denken, aber tatsächlich gibt es
sehr wenige Beweise dafür, also haben Sie
wirklich keine Fälle in der mittelalterlichen
Zeit der Philosophen  In der islamischen
Art der islamischen Welt, die
mit Autoritätspersonen in Schwierigkeiten gerät, liegt
dies teilweise an dem Mangel an
Autoritätspersonen, weil es nicht wie im lateinischen
Crittendon ist, wo es eine Kirche mit einem
Papst und einer Hierarchie von
Bischöfen gibt  Im sunnitischen Islam gibt
es keine etablierte Kirche und keine einzelne
zentrale Autorität, die
religiöse Dogmen im
Allgemeinen als durchsetzt  o Säkulare Herrscher
in der islamischen Welt nehmen normalerweise nicht
die Haltung ein, auf
bestimmten
religiösen Dogmen oder philosophischen Dogmen zu bestehen,
es gibt Ausnahmen davon, aber eine Art
Ausnahme, die beweist, dass die Regel
im neunten Jahrhundert passiert, als die
abbasidischen Kalifen versuchten, eine bestimmte Einhaltung zu fordern
zu einer bestimmten Doktrin
, die besagt, dass der Koran erschaffen wurde und nicht
ewig, also müssen wir nicht auf die
Gründe dafür eingehen, aber ihr Versuch,
auf dieser Doktrin zu bestehen und
sie als Dogma in ihrem Bereich zu fordern, war
ein Fehlschlag  die Menschen widersetzten sich und
schließlich ließen sie die Politik stillschweigend fallen
, und es scheint, dass die
Kalifen danach versuchten, ein
wenig von dieser Art des Beharrens auf
bestimmten Lehrmeinungen Abstand zu nehmen, und sei es nur,
weil sie bei ihrem ersten Versuch erfolglos waren,
sicherlich keineswegs der
Fall  dass weltliche Autoritäten
sich aus religiösen Angelegenheiten völlig heraushielten, aber
allgemein gesagt, dass die
Bestimmung des richtigen
Glaubens den s überlassen wird  Gelehrte, der Kreis Ulama
in der mittelalterlichen islamischen Zeit und die
was bin ich im Allgemeinen, haben
keine Polizei, ich meine, sie sind
an den Gerichten beteiligt und so weiter, aber sie sind
nicht in der Lage,
herumzugehen und den Glauben aller zu testen  für die Orthodoxie und
sie ins Gefängnis zu werfen oder sie
hinzurichten, wenn sie den Test nicht bestehen, und tatsächlich beschuldigten Theologen und Ghazali im 12
hätte zu Recht für seine
Lehren getötet werden können, und das war
zu diesem Zeitpunkt im 11. frühen 12.
Jahrhundert eine sehr neuartige Idee, und es ist keine wirklich gute Idee, es
scheint auch viele praktische Konsequenzen gehabt zu haben
, wie ich sage, Sie
don  Es gibt keine Philosophen oder
Theologen, die wegen ihrer Lehren hingerichtet oder inhaftiert werden.
Manchmal
werden sie
aus anderen Gründen wie politischen Gründen hingerichtet oder ins Gefängnis
gesteckt  Im 12. Jahrhundert mit einem
Philosophen namens Sukhavati, einem reinigenden
Denker, der
auf Befehl von Saladin tatsächlich hingerichtet
wurde, weil er zu viel Einfluss auf
den Sohn eines Sauna-Deans ausübte, gibt es ein weiteres
Beispiel eines frühen Mystikers namens Baja Lodge,
der wahrscheinlich getötet wurde  Tod für seine
radikalen Lehren teilweise, aber im
Allgemeinen sind dies die Ausnahmen, also hat man
in der islamischen Zeit des Mittelalters
und sogar bis in die frühe
Neuzeit in der islamischen Welt ziemlich viel Gedankenfreiheit, also ist die
Situation dort wirklich ganz anders
aus dem lateinischen mittelalterlichen Europa ok, also
wie wäre es, wie Sie es getauft haben, wie ist die
Situation jetzt? Nun, hier müssen wir
erkennen, dass es nicht immer gleich ist,
je nachdem, wo Sie sind und wann Sie
sind und im Mittelalter die
Situation und was Sie entkommen könnten
mit kann sozusagen ganz
anders sein
lassen Sie mich zunächst etwas Allgemeines über
die Tatsache oder diese Art von Annahme
eigentlich sagen, dass mittelalterliche thi  nker sind sehr
konservativ, sie halten sich gewissermaßen an die
Parteilinie,
sie überschreiten nie die Grenzen der
Orthodoxie, sie sind sehr darauf bedacht, im
Grunde immer wieder dieselben Dinge zu sagen,
die Theologen die ganze Zeit gesagt haben
, die eigentlich weit davon
entfernt sind, wahr zu sein, und der Grund dafür ist
dass es eine Menge praktischer oder
pragmatischer Überlegungen gab, die
Theologen und Philosophen dazu drängten,
auf innovative und
originelle Weise zu
denken  werden Meister oder
Lehrer sein, die um Studenten konkurrieren
und versuchen zu zeigen, dass sie
die brillantesten Logiker und
Philosophen, Theologen sind, weil sie
dann die meisten Studenten anziehen können, sie
können auch in der Hackordnung
innerhalb der Universität nach oben befördert werden und das
galt schon vor dem Aufstieg der
Universitäten, so dass wir
zum Beispiel aus dem
autobiografischen a einen sehr lebendigen Sinn bekommen  Der Bericht von Peter
Abaelard, über den wir sprachen, als
wir uns Abaelard und Heloise ansahen, erfährt
von ihm einen sehr lebendigen Bericht über seine
Konkurrenz mit anderen Meistern oder
Schullehrern zu der Zeit, als andere
Logiker, die eine rivalisierende Ansicht hatten
, davon spricht, sie zu widerlegen und sie zu machen
wie Idioten aussehen und so weiter, und
eines der Dinge, die er wirklich
betont, ist, dass er dadurch
viele Studenten anziehen konnte, sodass sein
Ruf für Brillanz
für ihn tatsächlich praktische Vorteile hatte, und
das ist auch in der
Zeit der Universitäten so der Fall  Anstatt
die mittelalterliche scholastische
Welt als eine Welt der Haida balint
Autorität zu betrachten, wäre es viel besser,
sie als eine Welt zu betrachten, in der
Autorität eine Art Grundlage bietet, auf
der weitere Überlegungen,
weitere Verfeinerungen, subtile Argumente, neue
Ideen und dann das angestellt werden können  Die Rolle der Verurteilung
und Unterdrückung durch die Behörden besteht darin
, dem ein Ende zu setzen, also gibt es ziemlich
viel Freiraum zwischen den
au  thoritäten, die viel unentschieden lassen,
vielleicht sind sich die behörden nicht einig,
also kann man vielleicht
spannungen zwischen agustin und aristoteles
zum beispiel finden und diese spannungen ausnutzen,
und dann gibt es all diese neuen ideen
, die im 12. 13. 14.
jahrhundert und dann auftauchen  Es war nur ein
Scholastiker, der sich zu weit von dem entfernte,
was als akzeptables
Dogma angesehen wurde, dass er in Schwierigkeiten geriet. In
gewisser Weise haben Sie hier also die
Scholastiker selbst, die sehr bewusst
versuchen, originell und kreativ zu sein, indem
sie sich auf kreative Weise mit ihnen auseinandersetzen
Autoritätsquellen, aber auch im Bewusstsein,
dass sie dabei vorsichtig sein müssen
und dass das Bedürfnis nach Vorsicht
in der islamischen Welt, würde ich sagen, nicht vorhanden ist,
aber sehr deutlich in der
lateinisch-christlichen Welt vorhanden ist, und man kann
tatsächlich viele Scholastiker sehen, so men
Scholastic  Denker gerieten in Schwierigkeiten, also
konnten wir schon wieder Abaelard
als Beispiel nennen. Ballards theologische
Schriften wurden untersucht, um zu sehen, ob das der Fall war
Sie arbeiten, um zu sehen, ob sie
ketzerisch waren, und er wurde tatsächlich
zu einer Art Prüfung gerufen und mit
allen möglichen bösen Konsequenzen bedroht, wenn er
sich nicht irgendwie von den Dingen zurückzog, von denen
er behauptet hatte, dass er offensichtlich nie wirklich
ins Gefängnis
gegangen war  nicht hingerichtet, aber im
13. Jahrhundert haben wir Roger Bacon,
einen interessanten Wissenschaftler, Philosophen, der
einige Zeit im Gefängnis verbrachte, nachdem seine
Lehren als ketzerisch eingestuft wurden. Wir haben
William of Occam, einen der berühmtesten
späteren Scholastiker im frühen
14  Avignon oder
Ivan Young vorgeladen, um Sir
wegen Ketzerei anzuklagen, er gerät später tatsächlich in
Konflikt mit dem Papst und flieht nach
München, weshalb ich das
eigentlich aufnehme, und er bleibt hier, weil er
bei einem antipäpstlichen weltlichen
Herrscher Zuflucht sucht, weil er das hat  Konflikt
mit dem Papsttum, aber es hat he vor, dass
er bereits später im 14. Jahrhundert nach Avignon gerufen worden war,
um sich wegen Ketzerei zu verantworten
ve John Wickliffe, dessen Bedeutung
englischer Theologe, der
bestimmte Themen
der Reformation zu antizipieren scheint, und er seine Lehren
wurden auch daraufhin untersucht, ob sie
ketzerisch waren, zwei der
von ihm inspirierten Philosophen, die danach in
Osteuropa Teil davon waren  eine
Art böhmischer nationalistischer Aufstand und
theologische Herausforderung für die Kirche.
Junge Gastgeber und Hieronymus von Prag, sie
wurden schließlich
im frühen 15. Jahrhundert auf dem Konzil von Konstanz hingerichtet,
und dies sind immer einige
Beispiele, also gibt es normalerweise viele Beispiele
für scholastische Philosophen
kommen aus dem Kontext der
Universität, die in Schwierigkeiten mit den Behörden gerät,
zumindest
gewissermaßen von einigen der Dinge zurücktreten
müssen, die sie gesagt haben, und wenn sie das nicht tun,
tatsächlich ins Gefängnis geworfen werden oder schlimmer
ein relevantes Beispiel, das ich meine  Mein
griechischer Clarett ist ein weiterer Bergscholastischer
Philosoph, der
mystischer ist und sein Name ist Meister Eckhart
Er ist also ein deutscher Denker, der
vom 13. bis zum 14. Jahrhundert lebte, und
Akkad wurde erneut der Häresie beschuldigt,
einige seiner Lehren wurden daraufhin untersucht,
ob sie orthodox waren oder nicht, und er
wurde zu Lebzeiten nicht wirklich
verurteilt, aber das liegt
nur daran  Er starb eines natürlichen Todes,
bevor er verurteilt werden konnte, weil der
Prozess noch im Gange war, als er starb,
und posthum wurden einige seiner
Lehren verurteilt. Dies ist ein interessanter
Fall für uns in diesem speziellen Vortrag,
weil einige Leute denken, dass
Eierkarton von einem Araber beeinflusst wurde  Parade oder
hatten Zugang zu ihren Lehren
und sicherlich gibt es einige
Ähnlichkeiten, also werden
wir zum Beispiel bei
Marguerite unter anderem sehen, dass sie die
Idee betont, Ihren Willen aufzulösen oder
Ihren Brunnen in den Willen Gottes einzufügen
und das ist ein Thema, das auch
bei Eckhart sehr stark präsent ist, also sage ich immer wieder
, dass es wichtig ist, bei
diesen Denkerinnen immer nicht nur an das zu
denken  Sie als Denkerinnen zu betrachten, aber daran zu
denken, sie in ihrer eigenen Zeit und an ihrem eigenen Ort zu verstehen,
und oft stellt sich heraus,
dass der relevanteste Vergleich für eine
bestimmte Denkerin möglicherweise nicht eine
andere Denkerin, insbesondere aus einer
anderen Zeit, ist, sondern ein männlicher Finger
, der es ist  ungefähr zeitgleich und
eigentlich denke ich, dass die wahrscheinlich größte
Resonanzfigur bei Marguerite
nicht die anderen Mystikerinnen sind, die
wir uns angesehen haben, ob wir uns das
ansehen werden, also denke ich nicht, dass ich hässlich bin, das
ist so sehr wie Filter bekam  Meinung zum
Beispiel oder Julian von Norwich, und tatsächlich,
wie wir sehen werden, ist sie aggressiv
gegen eine bestimmte Art von Askese
, die man bei einigen weiblichen mittelalterlichen
Mystikern findet, insbesondere bei Katharina von
Siena, über die sie beim nächsten
Mal sprechen werden, damit sie '  Eigentlich sind es
große Meinungsverschiedenheiten, die mehr
als einige dieser anderen
Mystikerinnen erreichen. Ich sehe tatsächlich, dass sie
intellektuell
Meister Eckhart ziemlich nahe steht, und angesichts dessen
interessant, dass Echo einer der
Denker ist, die mit den Behörden in Schwierigkeiten gerieten
und deren Lehren
als verdächtig, wenn nicht schlimmer angesehen wurden.
Eine Sache, die ich gesagt habe, ist, dass sich dieses Muster
der Verurteilung und
Unterdrückung von Zeit zu Zeit ändert und
insbesondere  scheint im Laufe
des Mittelalters immer gefährlicher zu werden, so dass
im frühen Mittelalter nicht
sehr viel Gewalt gegen Menschen ausgeübt wird
, um ihre intellektuellen
Lehren unter Kontrolle zu halten, es
scheint eine Art Wendepunkt im frühen
13. Jahrhundert zu geben  der sogenannte Alba-
Jensen-Kreuzzug in Südfrankreich
gegen die Katharer, also waren die Katharer
eine Gruppe von Christen, die
aus verschiedenen Gründen für ketzerisch gehalten wurden, und
wie Sie vielleicht wissen, gab es einen großen
Feldzug, bei dem es Kriege,
Kriege und Schlachten gab  und
Südfrankreich über diese Angelegenheit im
Grunde die Kirche, die Armeen unterstützt
, die vom König von Frankreich
nach Südfrankreich geschickt werden, um sie auszulöschen  diese
Katharer-Häresie und ziemlich viele Menschen
wurden im Zusammenhang mit der
Katharer-Häresie hingerichtet, und das scheint meiner Meinung nach in gewisser Weise
die Vorstellung zu
normalisieren, Menschen aus doktrinären Gründen hinzurichten,
weil man das nicht
wirklich so sehr sieht  Das 12. Jahrhundert
und früher im Mittelalter
hat mich natürlich auch für
unsere Zeit relevant gemacht, was in Frankreich passiert ist, und
tatsächlich scheint Frankreich im 13. und frühen 14. Jahrhundert eine Art
Epizentrum für die Verurteilung von Häresie und
unorthodoxen Ansichten zu sein,
weil nicht  Sie
haben nur den Aufstand der Katharer und die
Reaktion darauf, aber Sie haben den
berühmtesten Fall der Verurteilung im
Mittelalter, der in den
1270er Jahren in Paris stattfand, offensichtlich dieselbe Stadt,
in der die Dichterin der Margarete
hingerichtet werden soll, nur wenige  Jahrzehnte später, also
bevor wir zu Marguerite kommen,
lassen Sie mich endlich ein wenig darüber sagen,
dass es zwei
Runden von Nationen gibt, die von
t weitergegeben wurden  Der Bischof von Paris, die erste
Verurteilung, ist eine Liste von nur 10
Artikeln, die an der Universität nicht gelehrt werden dürfen,
und dann gibt es eine viel
größere, längere Liste von Artikeln, mehr als
200 Artikel
, die 1277 verboten wurden. Darauf
beziehen sie sich normalerweise, wenn sie
Das Gespräch über das Kondom der Pariser Nationen
ist ein Thema, das viel
Aufmerksamkeit von Philosophiehistorikern erhalten hat,
zum Teil, weil es scheint, dass eines der
Ziele, und dies überrascht uns,
eines der Ziele, Thomas von Aquin ist, der heute
als der maßgeblichste
Lehrkern angesehen wird  Figur der katholischen
Geistesgeschichte, dann aber
als so etwas wie eine, wenn nicht abtrünnige
Figur, aber zumindest geringfügig oder als
unorthodoxer Denker zu verschiedenen Themen angesehen wird, und
wenn Sie die Liste der
verurteilten Artikel mit Thomas als
Lehre im Hinterkopf lesen, wenn Sie genug
über Thomas wissen  Sie können tatsächlich
einige Resonanzen sehen, die die Kondomnationen
für eine Art Gelegenheitsleser oft überraschen,
weil sie unb sind
in vielen Fällen möglicherweise technisch, so dass Sie
auf verdammte Artikel gestoßen sind, wie zum
Beispiel, dass es verboten ist zu lehren, dass
Gott nicht mehr als eine Sache derselben Art erschaffen kann, es
sei denn, die hergestellten Dinge
haben eine Bedeutung. Es ist so, was
bedeutet das überhaupt, egal  Warum sollte der
Bischof von Paris es für notwendig halten, es
zu verurteilen, oder ein anderes Beispiel wäre,
dass es uns verboten ist zu lehren, dass Gott
nicht in der Lage ist, den Kosmos von seinem
gegenwärtigen Standort zu bewegen, also scheinen dies die besten
zwei sehr abstruse Dinge zu sein, über die man sich
Sorgen machen muss  und es ist ziemlich schwer zu
glauben, dass der Alltagsgläubige, wie Sie
wissen, in den Straßen von
Paris herumläuft, wir uns Sorgen darüber machen, ob Gott
den Kosmos bewegen kann oder ob
Gott mehr als eine Sache schaffen kann, die
immateriell, aber von der gleichen Art ist, aber in
der  Im Zusammenhang mit den scholastischen Debatten
, die wir in den 12th
Avenues der Universität Paris führen, macht es tatsächlich
ziemlich viel Sinn,
das erste Beispiel Thomas von Aquinas
actu zu nehmen  Ein Verbündeter sagte, dass Gott nicht
mehr als einen Engel der gleichen Art machen kann,
denn wenn er
zwei Engel macht, sagen wir, Engel A und Engel B,
und sie genau die gleiche Art von
Engel sind, dann gäbe es nichts, was
die beiden unterscheiden könnte, weil sie
sind nicht aus Materie, also befinden sie sich nicht an
verschiedenen Orten, und sie teilen alle
ihre anderen Eigenschaften, weil
sie genau die gleiche Art von Wesen sind,
wo sie alle die gleichen Merkmale haben,
und deshalb konnte Gott sie einfach nicht so
unterscheiden  müssen ein und derselbe
Engel sein, weil sie keine Möglichkeit haben, sie zu
unterscheiden. Ich werde nicht auf
alle metaphysischen Gründe
eingehen, warum er darauf besteht, aber anscheinend hat dies
die Behörden provoziert, weil es so
aussieht, als würde er leugnen, dass Gott etwas tun
kann, was aussieht  wie das Leugnen von Gottes
Allmacht würde Aquin natürlich sagen
, dass ich nur leugne, dass Gott etwas tun
kann, das an sich
unmöglich ist, und niemand denkt, dass
Allmacht beinhaltet, Dinge tun zu können
, die unmöglich sind, also wh  Das ist das
Problem, aber das Komitee, das diese Liste der verurteilten Artikel aufgeschrieben hat,
war offensichtlich anderer Meinung. Eine andere Sache, die es
wert ist, über diese Verurteilung gesagt zu werden, ist,
dass sie möglicherweise ironische oder
unbeabsichtigte Folgen hatte
oft gegen Menschen wie
Thomas von Aquin gerichtet waren, von denen angenommen wurde, dass
sie Theorien aus der Philosophie des Aristoteles übermäßig ergeben und ihnen verpflichtet seien,
könnte es gewesen sein, dass die Verurteilung
sozusagen die Bindung der Scholastiker
an die aristotelische Wissenschaft gelockert hat, was
in gewisser Weise eine gute Sache ist, weil sehr
der aristotelischen Wissenschaft war falsch, also
hier ein Beispiel. Gehen wir zurück zum
zweiten Fall. Ich erwähnte den verurteilten
Artikel über die Bewegung des Kosmos. Das
ist also eine sehr seltsame Idee, also haben Sie das
gesamte Buchuniversum, das für die
Mittelalter eine Kugel mit dem
Planeten wäre  Erde rot in der Mitte und die
Idee hier ist, dass laut dem
Komitee, das t geschrieben hat  Er verurteilte die
Kondomnationen. Gott sollte in der Lage sein
, das ganze Universum zu nehmen und es
nach links, sagen wir mal, nach rechts zu verschieben.
Okay, warum sollte ein Philosoph leugnen,
dass Gott das tun kann, weil Gott
allmächtig ist, also können Sie alles tun?
ist, dass irische Italiener leugnen, dass
es so etwas wie leeren Raum gibt, also
gibt es für sie keinen Raum um den
Kosmos herum außerhalb des Kosmos, der Kosmos ist
eine Kugel mit nichts außerhalb, nicht
einmal leerer Raum, weil Parasol eine
ganze Reihe von Argumenten gegen die
Möglichkeit hat  des leeren Raums, also wenn wir
auf der Erdoberfläche stehen und
nachts in den Nachthimmel blicken und wir
die Sterne sehen, die Sterne an der äußersten
Grenze des physikalischen Universums, und darüber hinaus
gibt es überhaupt nichts, nicht
einmal die Leere, natürlich die ERISA  Begriffe
sind falsch, was diesen leeren Raum
betrifft, und tatsächlich bestehen Körper hauptsächlich
aus leerem Raum, die aus
Partikeln bestehen, die im
leeren Raum herumschwimmen, und so könnte man an t denken  Die
Verurteilung des Zazz
ermutigt unwissentlich die Scholastiker, einen
Schritt weg von einer falschen oder als Diversionslehre
hin zu einer wahren Lehre zu gehen, die
in der frühneuzeitlichen
Philosophie und tatsächlich im 14.
Jahrhundert vielleicht teilweise wegen der
Kondomasiaten dominant wird  Es gibt
einige Philosophen, die anfangen zu zeigen, dass
sie sich mit der
Idee der Realität der Leere viel wohler fühlen, jetzt kann das
alles etwas übertrieben sein, und Sie kennen
den netten ironischen Gedanken, dass
die Verurteilung im Allgemeinen sehr
kontraproduktiv war, weil sie tatsächlich sehr kontraproduktiv waren
führte zu kreativen Unterschieden und
innovativen Veränderungen weg von unserem
staatsfremden ISM, das wäre eine grobe
Übertreibung, und ich denke nicht,
dass wir die
Existenz von Verurteilungen in Paris oder
anderswo im Mittelalter feiern sollten, aber
ich denke schon  Es lohnt sich immer noch zu
bedenken, dass diese Art von Missionen
unbeabsichtigte Folgen haben könnte und vielleicht
noch wichtiger für  ra margarite Es ist
wichtig zu erkennen, dass die
Beweggründe hinter
Inhalten normalerweise sehr spezifisch und sehr einzigartig
für die Situation waren. Wenn wir also zum
Beispiel an Marguerite denken und warum
sie besonders sagte, ich meine, sie, was
mit ihr passiert ist, ist sehr ungewöhnlich, richtig, wir haben '  Ich
habe Hildegard nicht
zu unserem hohen Devich zurückgekehrt gesehen, sogar
in große Schwierigkeiten geraten. Ich meine, Hildegard hat
ihre Meinungsverschiedenheiten mit den
Kirchenbehörden, aber keiner von ihnen wurde jemals
mit Inhaftierung
gedroht, geschweige denn mit Hinrichtung,
während Marguerite sowohl eingesperrt
als auch hingerichtet wurde, und so denke ich eine  Worüber wir
nachdenken müssen, ist, warum das
mit Marguerite passiert ist,
warum sie angesichts dessen, dass
viele ihrer Lehren aus unserer Sicht
wie Dinge aussehen könnten, die wir in einigen
dieser anderen mystischen Autorinnen finden, also denke ich
, um das zu verstehen und
Eine Sache, die helfen könnte, ist, ein
bisschen mehr darüber nachzudenken, wer sie war,
damit wir eigentlich nicht viel darüber wissen,
wer sie war. Ich sollte a
Zunächst einmal, aber sie
scheint offensichtlich eine aristokratische Frau gewesen zu sein. Der
Grund für die Vermutung, dass sie
aristokratisch ist, ist, ich meine, offensichtlich ist sie gebildet,
was bereits darauf hindeutet, dass
sie sie benutzt oder Mr. Craddock ist, aber
wir wissen auch, dass sie Kopien ihres
Buches anfertigen ließ  und an andere Aristokraten
und sogar kirchliche Autoritäten wie Bischöfe geschickt,
also übernahm sie eine aktive Rolle bei der
Förderung ihrer eigenen Ideen, und wenn man
darüber nachdenkt, sind mittelalterliche Bücher
teuer, so dass selbst das Geld für das
Abschreiben von Büchern schon zeigt, dass
sie es tut  war eine wohlhabende Frau Einige
der zeitgenössischen oder fast zeitgenössischen
Texte über Marguerite deuten darauf hin, dass sie
wie eine Piratin und Methode von Magdeburg
eine
Backin war  Sie haben keine Keuschheitsgelübde abgelegt, aber
sie leben immer noch keusch, Lee, und sie
heiraten tatsächlich nicht. Es sieht so aus, als ob
die starken Beweise
dafür wirklich offensichtlich sind
Soweit ich das beurteilen kann, endet die meiste Geschichte. Ich
glaube nicht, dass sie wirklich
Teil der Viki-Bewegung war, aber sie macht
die Behörden vielleicht auf ähnliche Weise nervös,
und tatsächlich lebt sie ungefähr zu der
Zeit, als die Biggie-Bewegung
vollständig ist  beim
Papsttum in Ungnade gefallen, erinnern Sie sich also, dass es
im frühen Drittel des
frühen 13. Jahrhunderts genehmigt wurde. Im frühen 14.
Jahrhundert wurde die Baekje-Bewegung
vom Papsttum im Grunde genommen zum Erliegen gebracht, und so befinden
wir uns jetzt in einer Zeit, in der dies der Fall ist  Eine
viel provokativere Haltung, wenn
sie ein Biggie
war oder sogar irgendwie in einer Art lebte
, die die Behörden
an die Babybewegung erinnerte, was
auf jeden Fall auf sie zutrifft, ist,
dass sie keine Nonne war  sie ist nicht
wie Hildegard innerhalb der anerkannten religiösen Hierarchie, also wenn Sie noch
einmal an die Streitigkeiten denken, die
Hildegard mit
Kirchenbehörden hatte, ging es um Dinge wie das
Begraben eines Mannes auf ihrem Friedhof
Kloster, als er angeblich war, wie
mitgeteilt, dass es darum ging, ob eine
Nonne von ihrem
Kloster in ein anderes Kloster verlegt werden sollte. Dies ist im
Grunde fast das Äquivalent von
Akademiker im Kampf oder institutioneller
Politik
waren radikal
problematisch oder gefährlich, und ich denke, ein
Grund dafür ist, dass sie sich direkt
in der institutionellen Hierarchie befand, und ich
erinnere mich, dass sie auch
in gewissem Maße Zustimmung von der Hierarchie suchte, also
schreibt sie an Bernard von Clairvaux und
bittet um Erlaubnis
, ihre Visionen effektiv zu veröffentlichen
während  Was Marguerite tut, ist,
außerhalb dieser Hierarchie zu stehen und
ihre Ideen sozusagen selbst aufzuschreiben und sie dann
provokativ Leuten,
einschließlich Geistlichen, vorzulegen und zu sagen,
was Sie davon halten und was möglicherweise so
reagiert, wie Sie es erwarten könnten
besonders in
sagen die eher repressive Atmosphäre
des frühen 14. Jahrhunderts sicher  Sehr
viel repressiver als das, was wir im
12. Jahrhundert mit Hildegard hatten, sie
reagieren, indem sie ihr sagen, sie solle die Klappe halten,
und sie sagen, nein, nein, dieses Buch ist
inakzeptabel, Sie können diese Dinge nicht sagen,
und tatsächlich passiert, dass das das erste Mal ist, dass
sie  sie inspizieren das
Buch und entscheiden, dass es nicht
endgültig akzeptabel ist, und sie verbrennen es und
sie warnen sie, dies nicht noch einmal zu tun, aber
nachdem sie gewarnt wurden, bleibt sie bestehen und
sie fährt fort, ihre Ideen zu veröffentlichen, und
sie schreibt dieses Buch namens The Mirror
of  einfache seelen und die kirchlichen
behörden werden davon müde
sie sitzen im gefängnis ich denke wenn man annimmt
das man diese vermutlich ziemlich
bequeme oder sokratische dame ins
gefängnis stecken will wird sie zusammenbrechen und aufgeben und
sagen es tut mir leid das ich es nochmal aber weit gebracht habe
Aus diesem Grund weigert sie sich,
mit dem Prozess zu kooperieren
, der ihr Buch auf Orthodoxie prüfen wird, und
insbesondere weigert sie sich, einen Eid zu leisten
, der es dem Prozess ermöglicht, in Gang zu kommen,
also sitzt sie am Sitz  Für zwei Jahre zwischen
1308 und 1310, bevor der Prozess beginnen kann, ärgert sich
der Bischof von Paris
zunehmend über sie und
beschließt schließlich, ohne ihre Beteiligung
weiterzumachen  darin und sie haben sie zu Tode gebracht,
sie übergeben sie tatsächlich den
weltlichen Behörden von Paris und
lassen sie zu Tode bringen, also hat dieses Buch sie
buchstäblich umgebracht,
und wenn ich alles meine, ist das
ein ziemlich guter Grund, es sich anzusehen und
sehen, was da steht, das werden
wir jetzt tun. Das erste, was dazu zu sagen
ist, ist, dass es nicht auf Latein ist, also
wie Oberkiefer- und Haubenbild, das
sie in einer Umgangssprache schreibt,
die in diesem Fall Französisch ist, und wir haben
ein paar  von Manuskripten davon auf Französisch wurde
es auch in andere
Sprachen übersetzt, einschließlich Englisch, aber nicht
immer mit Modis Namen im Anhang, so dass das
Buch sozusagen sein eigenes Leben hat,
ohne dass die Leute wissen, wer es geschrieben hat  e es und das
Wissen, dass die Person, die es
geschrieben hat, dafür hingerichtet wurde, ist es anders als
alles andere, was wir bis zu einem gewissen Grad gesehen haben
wie eine
philosophische Abhandlung, tatsächlich liest es sich
sehr ähnlich wie ein philosophischer Dialog,
wie ihn Plato geschrieben haben könnte, außer
dass die Charaktere, die miteinander sprechen,
keine echten oder
historischen Personen sind, sondern
Personifikationen, also gibt es eine ganze
Reihe von Personifikationen  die
hereinkommen, sie repräsentieren alle abstrakte
Ideen, aber die Hauptprotagonisten sind
drei, also gibt es eine Seele, die in
gewisser Weise Marguerite für sich
selbst zu repräsentieren scheint, und sie nimmt Ratschläge von der
Liebe an, die ständig mit einer
Figur namens Vernunft argumentiert, so effektiv,
was passiert, ist das  Die Liebe berät
Marguerite solo mit schockierenden Ideen, die
teilweise schockierend genug sind, dass sie
sich selbst getötet
und dann Marguerite in einem o vermarktet hat  Ein sichtbares
Zeichen ihres Bewusstseins, dass dies radikale
Vorstellungen sind, steckt sie in eine andere Figur
namens Vernunft, die sich immer
wieder gegen das wehrt, was die Liebe sagt,
und sagt, wie kann man sagen, was
bedeutet
das nicht, dass Tourette achill klingt und
es gibt  deutet durch die ganze
Sache an, dass Geld sich sehr bewusst ist, dass
das, was sie sagt, nicht nur radikal ist, wie
ich sage, sondern sie in Schwierigkeiten bringen könnte, dass sie davon
ziemlich unbeeindruckt ist, es scheint so
, dass sie sogar
gleitende und abwertende
Hinweise auf die Kirche einschließt  Hierarchie zum
Beispiel spricht sie von der himmlischen
Gemeinschaft als der heiligen Kirche der Größeren
und bezieht sich auf die Kirche hier auf Erden
als der heiligen Kirche der geringeren und offensichtlich ist
es ein wenig schmeichelhafter Vergleich, der an
sich eigentlich nicht so seltsam ist, ich
meine zum Beispiel, von San Agustin spricht
die Stadt Gottes in der Stadt auf Erden und
die Stadt Gottes ist eine himmlische Stadt, es ist
nicht die es ist nicht die eigentliche
Institution der Kirche hier o  n Erde, aber
nichtsdestotrotz ist klar, dass das, was
Marguerite hier tut, anstatt
sich die Mühe zu machen, die
kirchlichen Autoritäten herabzusetzen, und wie gesagt, sie
hat auch diesen Charakter der Vernunft, der
nicht nur eine Art alltäglicher Intuition zu repräsentieren scheint,
sondern vielleicht die Art  von Dingen
, die scholastische Philosophen sind, also
Schulmänner von den Universitäten oder
Kleriker aus der Kirchenhierarchie, der
Grund dafür ist, dass der Charakter der Vernunft da ist
, um ihren Standpunkt zu äußern
und Liebeslehren zu kritisieren, die
natürlich Margarets Lehren sind, also lassen Sie es
mich geben  Ihnen eine Passage, in der wir sehen,
dass sie sagt, Männer der Theologie und
Gelehrte, wie sie
diese Schrift niemals richtig verstehen werden, Sie
müssen Liebe und Glauben gemeinsam Ihre
Führer sein lassen, um dorthin zu klettern, wo die Vernunft nicht kommen kann,
und dann in einer anderen Passage, in der sie sagt,
jeder Lehrer von  natürliche weisheit jeder
lehrer der buchgelehrsamkeit jeder, der darauf
besteht, seinen gehorsam gegenüber den tugenden zu lieben,
versteht und wird dies nicht als solches verstehen
Es sollte verstanden werden, dass
sie damit sagt, dass die Lehre
der Liebe, die in diesem
Buch dargelegt wird, etwas ist, das die Scholastiker
niemals wirklich verstehen werden, und tatsächlich
denke ich, dass es hier eine Art traurige Ironie
gibt, nämlich dass, wenn die Leute da sind  Die
Kirchenhierarchie bekam das Buch,
sie reagierten genau so darauf, wie
sie es vorhergesagt hatte, also verstanden sie es nicht
oder
sie hatten das Gefühl, es zu verstehen
, konnten es aber nicht akzeptieren, und sie sagten ihr
, sie sollten eine Kopie davon vernichten  was
sie geschrieben hat, und als das sie nicht davon
abhielt, wurde sie getötet, also was war es
, was sie sagte, das so radikal
als so gefährlich angesehen wurde, dass die
Idee, die Liebe zu Gott
als den primären Wert im Leben zu identifizieren, es sicherlich nicht ist
radikal und wird im Mittelalter in keiner Weise als
inakzeptabel angesehen, Sie
finden es in Bonaventura, und tatsächlich
finden Sie es in gewissem Sinne anomal
,
so dass alle Scholastiker sagen werden, dass die
Liebe zu Gott mindestens ist  Teil dessen, was es
bedeutet, ein guter Mensch zu sein. Wenn Sie also
ihre Hauptfigur diejenige nennen, die
in dem Buch Liebe lehrt, und indem Sie
immer wieder auf die Idee der Liebe zu Gott zurückkommen, wissen Sie
, was ich damit meine, dass sie uns an
etwas Ungewöhnlicheres erinnert  Text, wie wir ihn in Hutta
which und Meth-Heads gefunden haben, und sie greift auch
auf diese Art von höfischer Liebestradition zurück, ein
weiteres Zeichen dafür
ist übrigens diese Verwendung von Personifikationen,
also sehen wir das in Aufzeichnungen und
auch ein seltsames Bild, aber zusätzlich wir  Siehe
im Roman der Rose des späten 13.
Jahrhunderts Gedicht über höfische Liebe Ich
erwähnte, dass es letztes Mal auch eine
Anspielung auf einen antiken
Laienphilosophen und Boëthius ist, der ein Werk mit dem Titel Der
Trost der Philosophie schrieb, in dem die
Philosophie selbst als eine
Frau als eine charakterisiert wird  Personifizierung Dame
Philosophie, die kommt und Boethius Trost anbietet,
wenn er im Gefängnis ist, also spielt sie
auf all das an, aber es ist
nichts Radikales daran, Liebe als
Hauptfigur zu nehmen und Lo zu haben  Wir müssen
uns bemühen, die Seele so zu sortieren, dass sie Gott so
sehr wie möglich liebt und vielleicht in gewissem
Sinne alle anderen Erwägungen
zugunsten der Liebe zu Gott beiseite stellt, aber wenn Sie
an dieses Zitat zurückdenken, das ich gerade gelesen habe,
sagt es etwas darüber aus,
darüber hinauszugehen  Die Tugenden und dies ist eine
der Lehren,
auf die im Prozess gegen Marguerite ausdrücklich verwiesen wurde,
und die Begründung für
ihre Hinrichtung,
nämlich dass sie lehrte, dass an einem bestimmten
Punkt die Seele,
die Gott zu schätzen gelernt hat oder vielleicht die Vereinigung
mit Gott dachte, transzendieren kann  Tugend selbst und
hat eigentlich keinen Grund
mehr, ein guter Mensch zu sein, und das scheint sehr
radikal zu sein, also ist die Idee auf den ersten Blick,
dass, wo die christliche Kirche
dich lehrt, tugendhaft oder fromm
zu sein, großzügig zu sein, vielleicht keusch zu sein, vielleicht
innerlich  die Grenzen der Ehe, aber
es gibt all diese Dinge, die Sie
tun sollten, und die Kirche sieht
einen großen Teil ihrer Rolle darin,
das Verhalten der Menschen zu kontrollieren und
ihnen beizubringen, b  Habt ihr es gut,
dann kommt Marguerite und sagt: „Gut,
sicher für die meisten Menschen, aber für mich und
andere Seelen, die sich befreit haben, indem
sie völlig besessen von der Liebe
zu Gott geworden sind und alles andere aufgegeben haben, sind
die Tugenden nicht mehr relevant, und
das ist tatsächlich etwas, was sie sagt  in
ihrem buch so hier ist ein beispiel wir sagen wir
haben liebe sagen seele wird gerettet durch glauben
ohne werke und vernunft antwortet wie üblich
skeptisch um gottes willen
was bedeutet das
liebe antwortet es bedeutet dass so eine seele
so eine seele die zu nichts gebracht
hat  so großes inneres Wissen durch
die Tugend des Glaubens und so beschäftigt ist
, in sich zu erhalten, was der Glaube
ihr gibt, dann kann kein Geschöpf
in ihrer Erinnerung bleiben, sondern
vergeht schnell, weil der
Verstand dieser zunichte gemachten Seele
mit anderen bedrängt und beschäftigt ist  Wichtig ist, dass diese
Seele nicht mehr zu Werken fähig ist, und
zweifellos ist sie gut entschuldigt und
entlassen, dass sie ohne Werke glaubt,
dass Gott gut ist  und unverständlich, dass
so jemand ohne Werke durch den Glauben gerettet wird,
denn der Glaube übertrifft jedes
Werk, wie die Liebe selbst bezeugt, also gibt es
viel, was wir über diese Passage sagen könnten.
Eines möchte ich betonen, dass es
eine Art Vorwegnahme eines Themas zu sein scheint
dass wir in der protestantischen
Reformation richtig liegen. Wenn Sie also an den
Lutheranismus und den Calvinismus denken, auch wenn Sie
nur eine sehr vage Vorstellung davon haben, was in
der Reformation passiert, wissen Sie wahrscheinlich, dass
eines der Dinge, die betont wurden, ist
, dass wir nicht wirklich wissen, ob
Wir werden errettet, also ist es völlig
Sache Gottes, uns durch Gnade vorherzubestimmen oder nicht,
und Sie können die Errettung nicht allein durch gute Werke verdienen,
also mögen gute Werke eine gute
Sache sein, aber letztendlich ist Ihre Beziehung
zu Gott nicht etwas, das Sie
irgendwie erzwingen können  auf Gott, weil ich so ein
guter Mensch bin, und ich sehe hier in Marguerite tatsächlich
eine Art Schimmer einer
Vorfreude, nicht wie in
einem späteren 14. Jahrhundert, von dem Sie glauben, dass ihr
Alexei Johnny wh cliff würde  o Ich habe bereits
erwähnt, dass einer der Menschen
, die in Schwierigkeiten gerieten und getestet wurden, um zu
sehen, ob seine Ansichten
verurteilt werden sollten, tatsächlich wirklich auf die
Idee kommt, dass wir nicht wissen, wer
vorherbestimmt ist und wer nicht, wer Gnade empfangen hat
und wer nicht  Nicht wirklich,
Dima verbindet das nicht, aber was sie tut, ist,
sie sagt, vergiss die Idee, dass es darum geht,
mit Gott im Reinen zu sein,
nette Dinge zu tun oder gute Dinge in der
Welt zu tun, es geht nicht um deine Werke, es geht nicht
um die  Dinge, die Sie tun, es geht um Ihre
emotionale Hingabe an Gott, es geht um
Glauben, es geht um Liebe, es geht um
Liebe zu Gott, es geht nicht um die Dinge
, die Sie
tun  man kann die tugenden
hinter sich lassen so sagt die vernunft das verkaufte das
margarita
über erfahrungen keine gnade sie empfindet keine
sehnsucht ist des geistes seit
sie sich von den tugenden verabschiedet hat die
jedem frommen alle eine form von g geben  Ein gutes Leben und
ohne diese Tugenden kann niemand
gerettet werden,
ist sie nicht von ihrem Verstand abgeschnitten, dieser Seele, die so
redet, um zu bemerken, wie sehr sie
einen Grund zulässt, sich gegen
die Lehren der Liebe und die Arbeit
selbst zu wehren, aber sie hat verstanden, dass es Liebe war  antworte
überhaupt nicht
für Seelen wie sie, die die
Tugenden besser als jedes Geschöpf besäßen, aber
sie keinen Gebrauch von ihnen machen, denn sie
stehen nicht mehr so wie früher in ihrem Dienst, und s
e haben ihnen auch nicht lange
genug gedient, um fortan zu könn
n  frei werden, was sie da sagt, denke ich
, ist, dass die Tugenden einige wie die
Tugenden offensichtlich aus unserer Sicht eine schlechte Sache sind,
was sie damit meint, dass die
Seele Fortschritte macht und
Gott immer näher kommt und sich Gott verpflichtet
vollständiger lässt die
Tugenden binden, weil sie fast wie
eine Stufe auf einer Leiter sind, die sie nicht mehr braucht,
also durchläuft sie eine Art Phase, in der sie
ihre Tugend erreicht, was Sie vielleicht
aus Liebe zu Gott tun, aber dann zu Ihnen  komm zu s
Da ein tugendhaftes Leben oder eine tugendhafte
Lebensweise nicht die innigste
Beziehung ist, die man zu Gott haben kann, gibt es
etwas Höheres, etwas darüber hinaus
, und eine interessante Sache, die sie sagt,
ist, dass diese Seele immer noch die
Tugenden hat, sie nutzt sie nur nicht
Vielleicht ist eine Möglichkeit, darüber
nachzudenken, dass, wenn Sie diese
Person, die diese besondere Beziehung
zu Gott hat, auf die wir gleich eingehen werden,
wenn Sie sie in eine Situation bringen, in der
sie eine ethische Entscheidung
treffen müssten, sie es trotzdem tun würden  treffen vielleicht die richtige Entscheidung,
aber sie sind es nicht. Es ist nicht irgendwie
charakteristisch oder typisch für die Seele,
sich in einer ethischen Situation zu befinden, sondern es ist
typisch für sie, sich von
der Welt zurückzuziehen und
sich Gott von ganzem Herzen zu widmen, so schien es immer
ziemlich abstrakt, und ich denke, ein
Grund, warum es ziemlich abstrakt erscheint, ist, dass
wir noch keine wirklich
konkrete Vorstellung davon haben, was sie mit Tugend meint,
also habe ich gerade
darüber gesprochen  Ja, das deutet darauf hin, dass es
Dinge bedeuten könnte, wie alten Damen
über die Straße zu helfen oder nicht zu
viel zu Abend zu essen, oder vielleicht wissen Sie sogar, dass Sie
Ihrer Regierung gut dienen, aber ich glaube nicht,
dass sie das im Sinn hat, tatsächlich
scheint es, als Mugabe darüber sprach
Tugend, woran sie wirklich in
erster Linie denkt, ist das religiöse Leben, das
mit Askese verbunden ist, also wenn Sie an
Menschen denken, die in einem klösterlichen Umfeld leben,
zum Beispiel meine Tilda-Wache,
oder wenn Sie an Menschen denken, die
Abtötungen des Fleisches durchgemacht haben, wie
indem sie nicht gegessen haben  sehr viel wieder etwas, das
wir das nächste Mal sehen werden, wenn wir
über Katharina von Siena sprechen oder
solche intensiven körperlichen Leiden
wie Julian von Norwich, wir werden wieder wir werden
das nächste Mal über sie sprechen, ich meine diese
ganze Idee von so etwas  Askese
Leiden Verzicht auf die Freuden
der Welt das haben wir
Mitte des 13. Jahrhunderts bei den Beginenmystikern
dymatisieren gesehen das haben wir auch kommen sehen  g bis in die
Spätantike, wenn Frauen sich aus religiösen Gründen
in die Wüste zurückziehen und ein
asketisches Leben annehmen, das ist,
glaube ich, das, was sie mit Tugend meint,
also ist das asketische Leben für sie
bewundernswert, weil es ein Leben der
Hingabe an Gott ist  aber es ist nicht die
bewundernswerteste oder zumindest am vollständigsten
verwirklichte Art, sich
Gott zu widmen, es ist eine Art Schritt, wie ich sage, ein Schritt
auf einer Reise zu Gott, an dem Sie
vorbeigehen oder auf eine Leiter treten, über die Sie hinausklettern,
also wenn unsere  die beziehung zu gott
ist nicht von dieser art von
asketischer tugend geprägt,
was zeichnet sie aus naja, wir
hatten schon ein paar mal einen hinweis,
denn sie erwähnte in der passage, die
ich bereits herausgerannt habe, dass diese
seele am nächsten kommt  möglich ist für Gott
die Seele, die zu nichts geworden ist, also ist
dies das Thema der Vernichtung der Seele
oder der Auflösung der Seele und Gottes,
was wir auch in den Baekje-
Mystikern gesehen haben, aber er bekommt eine neue Art
von Wendung in Margarita I Thi  nk, das ist
übrigens das Interessanteste an ihr
, ich meine, das Annehmen in der Schifffahrt
ist eine interessante philosophische Idee in dem
Buch, sie verbindet es sehr mit
dem Brunnen, also was sie hier sagen will,
ist, dass die Seelen aus Liebe zu Gott
das tun  Hingabe an Gott gibt die Seele auf, ohne zu
wollen oder etwas anderes zu wollen oder zu begehren
, und Sie hier, wenn Sie
versucht sind, etwas anderes als Gott zu sagen, aber
eigentlich will oder begehren die Seele für sie nicht einmal
mehr Gott,
sondern geben auf,
unwillig oder  Wenn Sie selbst eine
Art Basis haben oder sich selbst negieren wollen,
vernichten Sie sich selbst bis zu dem Punkt, an dem
ihr Wille einfach weg ist und sie zu nichts geworden ist
, wie meine Lektüre sagt, und das einzige,
was übrig bleibt, ist Gottes Wille
will, aber ich denke, die Art und Weise, wie
sie damit umgeht, ist eher so, als gäbe es
Gottes Willen und Ihren Willen, und bei den meisten
Menschen sind diese beiden Dinge nicht dasselbe,
und die Ideen und dass Sie wollen sollten,
was Gott will, aber dann y
Du solltest überhaupt nichts wollen, denn was du
überhaupt nichts willst, das einzige, was übrig bleibt
, wird Gottes Wille sein, also ist hier eine Passage, wo
sie das besser ausdrückt als ich,
ohne Zweifel, also spricht die Liebe, sie
will
alles und will nichts, denn diese
Seele will  so vollkommen der Wille Gottes,
dass sie in ihrem Willen weder weiß noch kann noch will
, aber der Wille der Liebe Gottes hat
sie so stark in Gefangenschaft und sie
will nichts, weil das, was sie will und
was Gott will, in ihr so wenig ist im Vergl
ich dazu  was sie will, dass
sie nicht haben kann, was Gott will, dass
sie gut für ihren Willen wäre, ist nichts im
Vergleich zu der Fülle, die
sie niemals beginnen wird,
und dieser Wille ist durch den Willen Gottes,
also ist die ziemlich komplizierte Passage, wenn
Sie das fast verstanden haben  Eindruck, den sie dadurch erhielt
, wie oft
sie das Wort Wille und Arabisch verarbeiten konnte, also haben wir
diese Art von Verkettung von
Erwähnungen des Willens und die Idee ist, dass
sie nie bekommen kann, was sie
will  Weil es nichts gibt,
was sie wollen kann, was so
groß ist wie Gott, also ist die Idee, dass
sie das Wollen einfach
vollständig aufgeben und Gottes Willen übernehmen lassen sollte
, das scheint die Idee zu sein, jetzt könnten Sie
argumentieren, dass dies eine Art ist  In gewisser
Weise meine ich sogar, dass es nicht nur eine
herausfordernde und radikale Idee ist, besonders
wenn es bedeutet, die Tugend aufzugeben, denn
übrigens können Sie sehen, warum dies
bedeuten könnte, die Tugend aufzugeben, denn
typischerweise die Idee, selbst als Asket tugendhaft zu sein
ist, dass du
deine Wünsche so änderst, dass du, anstatt
zum Beispiel Reichtum oder ein Familienleben
oder sogar eine Art weltliches Glück zu wünschen
, Gott glücklich machen willst oder du
willst, was Gott will und so weiter,
und das wäre Tugend, und
sie sagt  jetzt vergiss das vergiss
das wollen ganz du sollst du solltest
gar nichts wollen das ist ihre idee und
du denkst vielleicht gut ist das überhaupt
möglich wie ist es möglich das
wollen ganz aufzugeben wie wie würdest du
Sogar weiterhin in der Welt zu tun, als
würdest du nicht einfach in einen
Stuhl fallen und dich nicht mehr bewegen, denn wie
kannst du, selbst du weißt, aufstehen und dich
um die Welt im Raum bewegen oder Essen bekommen,
würdest du nicht sofort sterben, wenn du
hat das Verlangen aufgegeben und gut und sie sagt
, dass das nicht der Fall ist, weil man immer
noch handeln kann, ohne einen Willen zu haben, und hier
vermisst sie besonders diesen Geist, sie sagt,
was auch immer diese Seele tut, sie tut es
wegen seiner lobenswerten Praxis oder
weil die Heilige Kirche es befiehlt  seltenes
Zugeständnis an die Kirche, aber nicht an
ihre eigene Sehnsucht, denn der Wille, der
die Sehnsucht in ihr auslöste,
ist tot, also ist unsere Idee hier, dass Sie immer noch so tun, als
würden Sie zum Beispiel einmal pro Woche in die Kirche gehen,
aber Sie  Du gehst nicht in die
Kirche, weil du Gott
glücklich machen willst oder weil du die
Kommunion empfangen willst oder so etwas, du gehst
einfach so, weil du
das tust, du gehst einfach mit dem
Strom mit, aber in dir selbst bist du  überhaupt keine Wünsche
haben, die Sie dazu veranlassen,
dass dies eine wirklich interessante Idee ist,
ob es möglich ist, ohne Motivation zu handeln,
ob es möglich ist, ohne Begierde zu handeln,
es scheint, als ob diese Seele
, die keinen Brunnen hat, zu nichts geworden ist, von der
sie sagt, dass sie es wert ist, sie auszulagern
Entscheidungen gegenüber der breiteren Gesellschaft
nur ein Spiegel dieser Gesellschaft zu sein und mitzumachen,
was immer die Gesellschaft von ihr will,
aber innerlich ist sie tot oder sie ist weg, aber
es gibt einen noch interessanteren
Einwand dagegen, den sie
selbst mit der Stimme der Vernunft vorbringt, und das
ist  Eigentlich eine meiner Lieblingspassagen
in dem Buch, also lese ich sie dir jetzt vor, die
Vernunft sagt, sagst du, dass die Seele
überhaupt keinen Willen hat, und die Liebe sagt wirklich
nein, ich sage das nicht für alles
, was sie mit ihrer Zustimmung will  ist das,
was Gott will, dass es ihr gut gehen soll, und
das will sie, damit der Wille Gottes
erfüllt werde,
keineswegs ihr eigener Wille, und sie kann dies nicht
von sich aus wollen, sondern es ist der Wille
von  Gott, der es in ihr will, und so ist es
klar, dass diese Seele überhaupt keinen Willen hat,
dass sie zwei Willen hat, okay, also, was hier vor sich
geht, gibt es einen, besonders
wenn Sie den vollständigen Kontext dieser Passage lesen,
denke ich, dass es klar wird, dass
Marguerite es ist  Die Sorge ist, dass sie sich einer
Art philosophischem Einwand
stellen muss, der die folgende
Form hat: Sie sagt uns, dass das, was wir haben wollen
, überhaupt nicht mehr gut ist,
aber keine Rolle spielt, so klingt, als würde sie
uns ermutigen, nicht zu wollen
Mit anderen Worten, es ist so, als würde man sagen,
der einzige Wunsch, den man haben sollte, ist
, keine Wünsche mehr zu haben, was
in gewisser Weise wie der
klassische Asket wäre, also der Asket von
jemandem, der sich dafür entscheidet oder versucht, keine zu
haben  Wünsche, die sie erfüllen wollen,
aber sie sieht, dass das
inkohärent ist, denn wenn Sie wünschen
oder nicht, dann haben Sie immer
noch einen Wunsch, Sie haben das, was Philosophen
einen Wunsch zweiter Ordnung nennen würden, einen
Wunsch, der ungefähr ein de ist  Sire, Sie
wünschen sich also, keine anderen Wünsche zu haben, und
das ergibt keinen Sinn. Ich denke, was sie
in dieser Passage sagt,
soll das Problem lösen, also sagt sie,
dass die Idee nicht so ist, wenn Sie aufhören zu wollen
Sie hören auf zu wollen, indem Sie
nicht wollen. Die Idee ist, dass Sie einfach
aufhören zu wollen, und wenn Sie aufhören zu wollen, lassen Sie
nur Gottes Brunnen zurück. Wenn Sie also zu dem
zurückkehren, was ich gesagt habe, bevor Sie sich
daran erinnern, dass ich gesagt habe, dass es zwei
Möglichkeiten gibt  Wenn man darüber nachdenkt, was die
Mystikerin zu tun versucht, wäre es zum einen
zu denken, dass die Mystikerin versucht,
sie gut mit Gott in Einklang zu bringen, so dass sie will,
was Gott will, und Marguerite
widersetzt sich dieser Denkweise,
stattdessen sagt sie, vernichte deinen Willen
vollständig  denn solange du immer
noch versuchst zu wollen, was Gott will,
willst du, dass deine Seele deinen
Willen ausübt, und solange du
deinen Willen ausübst, gibt es eine Art Abstand
zwischen dir und Gott, genau
wie du  einverstanden w  mit Gott
darüber, was passieren soll, aber du bist
immer noch anders als er, während
du dich, wie sie sagt, einfach in nichts verwandeln würdest
, wenn du vollständig
aufhörst zu wollen, dann ist das Einzige, was übrig bleibt,
Gottes Wille
, anstatt darüber nachzudenken, wie
wir uns daran ausrichten  Gottes Willen
sollten wir uns so vorstellen, dass wir
unseren Willen vollständig aufheben und Gottes
Willen über alles herrschen lassen,
und es gibt eine andere Passage, in der sie, glaube ich
, versucht, uns zu ermutigen, dass diese
Strategie funktionieren wird, also sagt sie, wenn diese
zunichte gemachte Seele Gottes Willen haben möchte,
sie  kann es nicht haben, weil
sie nur ein kümmerliches Geschöpf ist, aber Gott
will, dass sie sich das wünscht
und dass sie einen solchen Brunnen in einem
solchen Brunnen des göttlichen Willens hat, aber wenn
die Seele selbst etwas will,
was dies verhindert, so versucht sie es  zu sagen
ist, schau Gott versucht dir zu helfen Gott
will, dass du einfach er bist oder bist oder dass
dein Wille nichts als sein Wille ist und
du konkurrierst damit oder verhinderst, dass
es passiert b  Wenn Sie Ihren Willen ausüben,
indem Sie Wünsche haben, indem Sie Wünsche haben, und
sogar die Art von Sehnsucht, die wir
in meto de nada [ __ ] nach Gott gesehen haben, das wäre
genau das, was sie
sagt, wird nicht funktionieren, also diese Art von
verzweifeltem Sie wissen, quälendem
Herzen  - Zerreißende Sehnsucht und Sehnsucht nach Gott
, das ist etwas,
das dich für Marguerite tatsächlich von Gott wegbringen wird,
weil du dich so mit deinem
Verlangen nach ihm identifizierst, dass du nicht
einfach er werden kannst, was du eigentlich versuchen solltest,
ist irgendwie dahinschwinden  zu nichts
und nichts außer Gott hinter sich zu lassen,
also gibt es offensichtlich eine sehr radikale
Lehre, es ist auch eine sehr
philosophisch anspruchsvolle Lehre, ich
meine, es geht wirklich darum,
wie das Verlangen funktioniert, wie die
menschliche Psychologie funktioniert, und wie
gesagt, das ist es eigentlich nicht  Es ist klar, dass
das, was sie sagt, überhaupt möglich ist, also
bin ich nicht ganz davon überzeugt, dass es
möglich ist, vollständig aufzuhören, gesund zu werden,
und ich denke, der Haupteinwand, dem sie sich stellen muss
, ist genau  ly diese Idee,
die zweite Ordnung zu entfernen, nur
um eine Vorstellung davon zu geben, warum dies eine
interessante philosophische These sein könnte, also dieses
weitere Projekt Die Idee beginnt, wissen Sie,
den Willen aufzugeben. Ich möchte
den Vortrag beenden, indem ich ihn mit ein paar vergleiche
Dinge, an die es uns aus
der Geschichte der Philosophie erinnern könnte, also eine Sache, an die
Sie uns vielleicht erinnern könnten, ist der Buddhismus. Der
Buddhismus ist berühmt für die Idee
, das Verlangen aufzugeben, und daher kommt
die Idee hier, dies ist eine davon,
aus der Lehre von  der Buddha
selbst die Vier Edlen Wahrheiten, dass
man dem Leiden entkommen kann, indem man aufhört,
irgendetwas zu wollen, denn wenn man Dinge will
, leidet man schließlich, wenn
man sie nicht bekommt. Wenn man also überhaupt nichts wollte
, dann  Ich werde
nie traurig oder ängstlich darüber sein, nicht zu
bekommen, was Sie wollen, das
klingt offensichtlich sehr danach, als wäre ich nicht ganz so,
richtig, sie hat es auch gesagt, das
Ziel von Arc ihrer Philosophie ist es
, Wünsche zu beseitigen oder gut zu vervollständigen
Insofern klingt es ziemlich
nach Buddhismus, aber es gibt einen Weg, der dem
Buddhismus sehr unähnlich ist, nämlich
dass es im Buddhismus keinen göttlichen Brunnen gibt,
also ist die Idee, Ihren Willen zu entfernen,
damit ein anderer Wille die
buddhistische Idee übernehmen kann  ist, das Verlangen
vollständig zu entfernen, tatsächlich sollten Sie sogar
die Vorstellung aufgeben, dass Sie ein Selbst haben oder
dass Sie durch die Zeit als
Person bestehen,
es gibt überhaupt kein willendes Selbst oder eine Person
und Buddhismus, und wenn Sie das
sehen, kommen Sie dazu  Sie geben auf,
Wünsche zu haben, also denke ich, dass diese Vorstellung, dass
es eine Art externer Vorgesetzter gibt
, der hereinkommen und
Ihren Willen ersetzen soll, etwas ist, das auf
Margarite zutrifft und sicherlich nicht auf den
Buddhismus in meiner Erinnerung
Etwas aus der alten europäischen
Philosophie, das Stoizismus ist, also
ziemlich offensichtlich Stoiker wie Marcus
Aurelius oder Epiktet, hat nicht
viel mit meiner ihrer Tourette gemeinsam, aber ich
denke, es gibt immer noch einen Vergleich  Sohn, der
hier gemacht werden muss, da die Stoiker auch
an der Idee interessiert sind,
egoistische Wünsche aufzugeben, ein Verlangen nach, sagen wir,
Reichtum oder Familie, meine
ähnlichen Dinge, die ich zuvor erwähnt habe, weil
sie dich davon abgehalten haben, eine Vereinbarung
mit Göttern zu sein, so wie es die Stoiker getan hatten  diese
Idee, dass Gott das Universum durchdringt
und alles zu
Ende bringt, und das Stoiker-Zeitalter ist
die Person, die normalerweise ein Sohn ist, es wird ein
Mann, obwohl, wie wir die Stoiker gesehen haben, der
David ziemlich optimistisch ist,
ob Frauen tugendhaft sein können und könnten
Philosophieren, also versucht der stoische Weise,
sie mit den Göttern in Einklang bringen zu lassen,
tatsächlich sieht dieser Stoiker, dass seine Seele
in gewisser Weise ein Teil Gottes ist, aber ich
denke, die Hermelin-Ansicht kommt dem tatsächlich
näher  Idee, die ich
als Interpretation von Margaret aufgebracht und abgelehnt habe,
damit die Öfen nicht sagen, hör auf,
vollständig zu wollen, und dann wird Gottes Wille übernehmen,
was sie sagen, ist, deine Welt
mit G auszurichten  Gottes Wille ist also in gewisser Weise die Art von
klassischem ästhetischen christlichen Modell, das
Margaret hier selbst
vom Stoizismus ablehnt, und ich denke, dass sie
sich von diesem stoischen Modell distanziert, das
letztendlich sein historisches Modell ist, das die
Idee eines linierenden Jahreswillens von Gottes Willen
ist  im Grunde eine stoische Idee, und das ist,
was sie nicht will, was sie will, ist überhaupt nicht wollen, was sich
von einem Leben mit einem Willen unterscheidet, der
auf Gottes Willen ausgerichtet ist, und eine andere Art
von Denkschule, auch aus der Antike
, die wir vielleicht haben  Denken Sie hier an
Platonismus oder machen Sie Platonismus, weil sie
zu sehr die Idee haben, dass
Sie Wünsche aufgeben oder
Ihre Wünsche nach Dingen in der physischen
Welt minimieren und Ihren Willen oder Ihre
Wünsche mit denen der Götter in Einklang bringen sollten, aber
es gibt ein paar  inwiefern ihr
Unterricht anders ist als die Tellerlisten, so
ist ihr Unterricht zum einen
viel intellektueller als ihrer, also
geht es im Neuplatonismus
normalerweise nicht hauptsächlich um l  Liebe und es geht nicht
darum,
Gott will Gott und den Göttern wohl, es geht viel
mehr darum, das Verlangen aufzugeben, das
auf die physische Welt gerichtet ist, und
sich mit reinem Verstand oder reiner
Vernunft zu identifizieren, und wie wir gesehen haben, ist Marguerite
eine dieser Hausschülerinnen
Die Vernunft ist in gewisser Weise sehr eingeschränkt
und was sie tun kann, wenn Sie die
Tugenden hinter sich lassen, lassen Sie
in meinen Füßen auch die Vernunft hinter sich, aber
es gibt zumindest eine Möglichkeit, in der
Marguerite uns dennoch an die Oakland-
Ismen erinnert  ist, dass sie
auch diese Idee hat, dass die Seele
immer bei Gott war und es wirklich durch
Verlangen und Wollen war, dass sie überhaupt von Gott abgefallen ist, und
das scheint irgendwie neuplatonisch zu sein, also die
Idee, dass die wahre Heimat der Seele bei
ist  göttlich und dass es wegfällt, wenn man
Dinge in der physischen Welt begehrt
, das ist etwas, das wir sicherlich
in Neo Clayton finden könnten, das Tinus ähnelt,
also schätze ich, dass es bei all diesen drei Dingen Glocken läutet,
Budd  Sein Stoizismus und Platonismus,
aber meiner Meinung nach ist es eine wirklich innovative und einzigartige
Lehre, die
nicht vollständig mit diesen übereinstimmt und eine
der bemerkenswertesten Reflexionen über die
Natur des Brunnens ist, die wir im
Mittelalter erhalten, die wirklich
etwas aussagt weil  Tatsächlich ist der menschliche
Wille und die Natur des Begehrens eines
der Themen, die
in der scholastischen mittelalterlichen
Philosophie zu ihrer Zeit um 1400 am ausführlichsten diskutiert
wurden, daher denke ich, dass sie
wirklich als eines der interessantesten ernst genommen werden sollte
Philosophen
um die Wende vom 13. zum
14. Jahrhundert das ist kurz nach
Aquin um die Zeit von SCOTUS und
Holcomb Ich denke, sie ist eine der wichtigsten
Denkerinnen des Mittelalters, und deshalb war ich froh, dass
ich ihr beim nächsten Besuch einen Vortrag widmen
konnte  Schauen
wir uns jedoch einige andere weibliche Denker an, deren Ansichten der Art von Askese viel näher kommen, von der ich dachte, dass sie sie ablehnt, die wir uns ansehen werden  die
ästhetischste Frau des Mittelalters, die
vielleicht Katharina von Siena ist, und
dann schauen wir uns Julian von Norwich an und
sprechen über einen anderen Text, der sich
um die Idee dreht, Visionen von Gott zu haben,
und die Bedeutung dieser
Visionen so ähnlich kommentiert  Was
wir gesehen haben, war ein Garten, den sie
Mystikern gaben und weniger wie mein Schicksal. Ich hoffe,
Ihnen hat der Vortrag gefallen, und kommen
Sie beim nächsten Mal dazu